guys it's getting really really bad
April and May were seemingly nothing
when it comes to coronavirus compared to
what it is we are increasingly facing
right now we are seeing new coronavirus
records almost daily and these are not
the types of records you want to be
setting remember that for the Trump
administration we beat this thing in May
it's over I mean we're months past
victory now it's true that other
countries did almost beat this thing
they are reopening safely they've
crushed their curve and life is looking
more and more normal and it's true that
parts of the US are reopened almost
completely but those parts of the US are
seeing some of the worst outbreaks in
the world if Florida or Arizona were
countries alone they would be some of
the worst countries in the world to be
in from the standpoint of coronavirus so
let's just look at the data Florida
yesterday set the all-time high ever for
any single day new cases in any of the
50 US states Florida had more than
15,000 new cases yesterday this is way
worse this is thousands more than even
New York had at the worst point in its
outbreak I was what it's making global
headlines how bad things are in Florida
I was watching Argentinian news this
morning and they said breaking news the
United States state of Florida set a
record we've never seen anywhere
meanwhile on Friday in the US again I've
been saying this type of thing for
months because it keeps getting worse
the u.s. set the single day record for
cases with almost 72,000 cases in one
day there are now a record estimated
1.75 million active cases in the United
States almost three and a half million
cumulative cases and then the deaths you
know we were hoping I was cautiously
optimistic that something different
would happen that even though the case
has started spiking around June 19 that
deaths would not spike 20 days later but
sadly right on cue 20 days after the
case has spiked we saw last Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday deaths back
up to the 750
to a thousand per day range and it is
believed that those deaths are tied to
the cases from around June 20 to 25
early July was way worse in terms of
cases and if indeed we're going to see
the same pattern next week is going to
be very very ugly so there are about
three layers of I'm disappointing that's
not really the word three layers of
dismay here when it comes to what's
going on first we know the
administration failed they don't seem to
care Trump is golfing he's not talking
to foul Chi I'll tell you about that
later that's number one we know it could
have gone better
because just about every other country
did better the proof is there there's
nothing unique about the you know
they'll say well these other countries
are less free than the United States no
they're more smart South Korea ranks
higher on the democracy index than the
United States when you hear the only
reason South Korea did what they did is
because they they're not free the way we
are according to the democracy index
South Korea is more free than the United
States second we are in this situation
partially because of the administration
yeah that's true but partially we're in
the situation we are because of
Governors and the people in the states
now that's on both sides what I mean by
that is Trump failed that's the the
starting point in some states governors
and people took things seriously I'm not
you know some people say I brag about
Massachusetts I've privileged to live in
a wealthy state like Massachusetts
listen I just know what's going on here
you see masks everywhere schools are
closed almost all summer camps other
than some very specific you know
physically distant camps that are
possible utmost caution here and in fact
people are getting worried that we're
doing too much by by letting restaurants
do indoor dining I don't think we should
in other states
people who think masks and vaccines are
the problem are sort of joining forces
with ignorant governors to let the
situation run rampant so that's
horrifying that's the second piece which
is that as Trump failing aside you have
a dramatically different population in
different parts of the country and
different governors who have handled
this very differently and you can see it
in the case numbers
and then number three of course is that
we've done so little but we're
pretending like it was just beyond our
control that's a very disturbing
attitude you just look at other
countries we chose to handle this
differently than other countries some
states did it one way some states that
another way but we're almost saying
we're all out of ideas except we've done
almost nothing and they're looking at
reopening Disney World when Florida got
15,000 new cases in a single day
it's truly vile and all we can do is you
know one of the tough things for me has
been relinquish inquiry I never had
control but recognizing that I just lack
the control to really affect this at the
big picture all I can do is okay I've
chosen to live in a state that I
predicted would handle things well
generally speaking and I'm lucky in that
sense and I live in Massachusetts I can
wear my mask I can be safe I can tell
people what I think makes sense to do I
can't control everything I can't control
the vaccines and that's a really tough
thing right now for people who see how
we've gone wrong
from day one tomorrow night please join
the David Pakman show third David Pakman
show chess tournament 8:00 p.m. Eastern
Tuesday July 14 I will be playing
everybody can play register for free at
david pakman.com slash chess I will also
livestream my participation and secondly
tomorrow same day Tuesday July 14 we
will do be doing a big one-day
membership special we're trying to dig
out of a 300 member hole that happened
on July 4th when a bunch of 20 19
members had to cancel because of the
virus so we're gonna try to dig out of
that tomorrow with a one-day membership
special if you want to be notified about
it very easy just go to david pakman.com
and get on my newsletter get sign up for
the newsletter you'll see where to type
in your email address on the right side
of the website tomorrow you'll get a
beautiful email from me telling you how
to take advantage of this discount in
the meantime tell me how things are
looking in your state I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman